awesome
yeah thank you everybody for for joining
i hope you're enjoying the the
conference um so today we're going to
have a very interesting set of topics so
we're going to cover quite a broad range
of the
machine learning life cycle
and we're going to talk about some best
practices that can be adopted and used
at the different stages
of this machine learning life cycle as
you productionize your model
particularly around optimizations so a
bit about myself my name is alejandra
saucedo i'm an engineering director at
cell and technologies so we do
machine learning deployment and
monitoring um we're the authors of one
of the most popular uh machine learning
deployment frameworks in kubernetes
called selden core
i'm also
chief scientist at the institute for
ethical ai where we develop frameworks
that contribute to the responsible
design development operation of uh
machine learning systems in production
so we recently contributed to various uh
european commission policies on data and
ai
very interesting ecosystem but i don't
want to bore you guys to sleep uh maybe
for the beers
um and um
shout out uh to elena from microsoft uh
with whom uh we did this uh
collaboration so this is a selden
microsoft and hugging face uh
collaboration so we've got some really
great um you know direction from the
hugging space team so we're very excited
um to you know not just showcase but
also get some feedback um
through the jupiter notebooks that you
guys can try out in the documentation
itself
so what we're going to be doing today is
we're going to be talking about the
motivations of machine learning
acceleration
and also the challenges when it's not
just for one model but at scale
we're going to take a hands-on example
we're going to be using
the
hyped uh gpt2
machine learning model uh perhaps the
next talk is going to be using the dali
model and especially with the hugging
phase integration we can now uh build
some crazy looking avocados
um then after that we're going to be
running
the model locally so that we validate
that our packaging works as expected as
the last thing that you want is putting
it in production and then having to as
we were just discussing call your devops
team to send you the logs
so
that's that's one of the key uh steps
that we're going to be delving and then
deploying the model um through some kind
of
ways in which we can optimize the
artifact itself but also optimize the
performance of inference of the model
itself
then we're gonna you know touch upon
very briefly i know that you know this
is a pi data conference uh specifically
on the python on the data science uh not
a kubecon so we're not gonna be talking
too much about the kubernetes because
again i don't want you guys to to fall
asleep but again you know if you're
interested uh we can delve into that
during the questions or
afterwards
um so yeah talking a bit about uh the
envelopes uh best practices and some
things that you can put in place and
perhaps even as machine learning
practitioners uh point this to your
machine learning engineer teams or
devops teams so that they adopt it um in
that way you don't have to deal with
kubernetes and everything is uh
programmatic automation behind that so
let's start with the what uh
i guess just uh hands up of people that
know of gpt2
see if i have to explain it great about
90 percent um all right well so uh just
for the other 10 uh gpt2 model is a tech
generation model it basically
takes a input string as tokens and it
generates the next token
what this allows you to do is generate
human looking text
or human
sounding human reading text
that actually is used in some really
interesting applications the why is we
have actually seen
both really interesting and some
controversial use cases of gpt2
this one dungeon ai if you may have come
across it it's basically a dungeons and
dragons like text based game where you
choose your adventure you say hey i've
been dropped off into this magical world
what do you do next and then you type i
will then go
xyz and then it responds what what
you're looking to do um of course what
they didn't expect was that uh the
internet came in and uh started doing
really uh dodgy and weird stuff with it
uh and regexis are not enough uh to just
filter some of those uh crazy use cases
but today we're not gonna be delving
into uh the nuances uh i do have an ai
ethics talk uh that i actually gave out
the pi data last year so i also
recommend you uh to check that one out
if you're interested in that general
topic and then the how so this is the
thing that we actually talk about but
just in a more intuitive way we're going
to use uh the hugging face uh hub to
pull the pre-trained models so we're not
going to be sitting here for a couple of
hours until our models train we're going
to be using those pre-trained artifacts
then we're going to perform some
optimizations using the hugging phase
optimum library we're going to talk
about what that means as well as what
the formats
available are in this case the onyx
format
and then we're going to be
as i mentioned running it locally with
our server called ml server once we're
ready we're going to deploy this into
kubernetes uh using seldom core and then
productionizing our stack but we're
going to be focusing mainly on uh the
points on the top uh as a reminder so um
you know the code examples and links uh
you'll find them in the slides and you
know all of that was in this bit a while
link at the top which will be at the end
of the slides as well
so if you want to try anything that
we're showing you can it's in the
documentation if you can't find it
so please check it out something breaks
open a github issue that's the beauty of
open source so let's start with the
first step uh so fetching the model with
the hugging face hub so this is actually
quite simple uh the only thing that we
need to leverage given that we're using
a pre-trained model is we can first
fetch the model itself and we're going
to explain what that actually means from
an intuitive perspective so you can do
the tokenizer from pre-trained that
actually loads the tokenizer and then
loading the model from pre-trained again
this actually goes into the hub and
finds the the repo
with this specific name you can then
build the pipeline which simplifies a
lot of the steps for inference but just
to give you a little bit more of an
intuition of what's actually happening
under the hood let's say that we have
this input text
this string i love artificial
intelligence
what we need to do in order to
run through run this through the model
to generate the next token we actually
have to convert it into tokens right so
basically um
machine readable uh uh
data inputs that we can pass to our
model we can use the tokenizer for that
that means that we run tokenizer.encode
we actually get those tokens we can now
generate that next token however you can
see that here we're generating multiple
tokens so this generate function has
some magic inside we're going to see
what that is but what this is doing is
actually generating multiple new tokens
so basically taking the text generating
one token then taking all the text plus
that token generating the next one etc
etc and then but by the end we have to
just decode it using our tokenizer
itself so now we have this
generated text i love artificial
intelligence but i'm not sure it's worth
so that's very simple now the only thing
to mention is that this generate
function has some magic inside
the way that you generate the tokens can
be basically um you know in a naive way
where the actual prediction the actual
response of the model itself gives you
uh you know all of the tokens with uh
the logits that um you know it predicts
as the probability of that next token
being
that generated one you can actually take
a greedy approach and just take the most
uh the one with the highest probability
at each step however
you can use other algorithms like beam
search
which in this case the generate function
does which actually has a look ahead
right it tries to generate um you know
best by looking at multiple uh steps
beyond as opposed to just a greedy
approach
so
you know the pipeline method that we
used here this actually
does all of that for us right so
whenever we run the prediction with our
pipeline it does kind of like that magic
for us and i'm just providing you some
of the intuition and this is something
that we're going to be reverting back
more importantly those parameters are
what we're going to be defining as our
machine learning as code when we are
deploying our
models
so now we go to the next step right of
course right now we could actually just
deploy that model if we want if we
wanted you know we could
even modify that model itself we could
do some transfer learning and then push
the new uh updated model into the hub
and then work with that uh in this case
we're going to be uh optimizing that and
by that we mean quantizing the model and
converting it into an output format that
can be optimized in this case the onyx
format so onyx is a standard that has
been worked now cross-functionally it's
part of
the linux foundation
was donated by microsoft and it provides
you know a standardized format to
represent models but also a standardized
format to be able to optimize uh the the
runtime of those models itself with
servers like triton
or the onyx runtime et cetera et cetera
um and you know if you have actually
used triton with onyx you may have faced
some of the pains uh of having to create
those config files so it's a little bit
not intuitive um at least initially
fortunately we can leverage uh one of
the newest libraries from hogging face
the one that we actually perform our
integration with which is the optimum
framework
so the optimum library provides an
interface to convert quantize optimize
our models
export them in tornix with
you know very similar interfaces to what
we saw so instead of just using our uh
you know tokenizer and model functions
we would use the optimum specific
functions that would allow us to
actually run and load those optimized
models itself and it would have kind of
like that onyx runtime in the background
so this is basically just telling you as
data scientists you can just stay within
python and interact with a very simple
kind of interface while still getting
the advantages of that sort of
underlying runtime that you know can be
optimized against uh you know um
specialized hardware like gpus or tpus
so okay so now we have the artifacts we
now have an optimized artifact now is
the next step of actually testing it
running it locally before we deploy it
for that we're going to be using this
library called ml server so before
talking about the actual steps we do
need to talk a little bit about the
complexities of going into the i have a
model that is ready to generate value
and be deployed and i already have it
generating value and it's running
consistently there are challenges on not
just specialized hardware we talked
about um you know the requirements of uh
things like gpus or tpus but
especially with transformer-based models
you will have some of them that require
a lot of memory right and when it comes
to that you have scheduling
considerations yeah you know even if you
want to perform optimizations that
involve
horizontal scaling
or vertical scaling that has
requirements on the hardware where you
run it with and how you optimize that
right if you have a bunch of like
scikit-learn models that are much
i guess smaller
you may want to actually leverage some
hardware for those versus the more you
know heavy ones on on the others so
that's that's one one one consideration
uh there are complex dependency graphs
there has been a lot of talks around uh
data centric machine learning so this is
actually quite important especially when
it comes to
you know transformer based models you
actually have a preprocessor model and
post-processor steps but even with other
uh models like you know with dali we
actually see that there are multiple
steps in the pipeline uh to generate you
know whether it's you know filtering
prioritization etc etc um and you have
you know use cases in machine learning
like uh you know recommenders uh systems
or you know search that those does
require a lot of different steps so so
there are complex dependency graphs uh
across the data flow uh there are
compliance considerations right if
something goes wrong if you need to
explain a prediction you need to have
the infrastructure to be able to go back
to rerun things to ensure that
everything is uh you know like the last
point reproducible and making sure that
that reproducibility goes not just
on the sort of atomic components of the
model that you're deploying but across
the overarching infrastructure right
remembering this data centric approach
that
you need to consider all of the
different parts at play including the
data
with the artifact that it runs at that
time so what we're going to be actually
skimming through but covering is how
we're going to be performing those steps
first the conversion of that you know
artifact into a fully fledged deployed
service
we're going to be first talking about
the ml server component right that's the
ability for a data or machine learning
engineer to be able to test it locally
but more importantly even build a
reproducible pipeline that then allows
for this to be automatic and then we're
going to be talking about you know how
that would allow you to go to the next
step which is actually the
productionization so running it locally
with ml server you know it's quite
simple you need to first just define
that pipeline programmatically
you then are able to run it locally with
some of the um
you know command line interfaces that
you have and then you can deploy it uh
as the follow-up steps
so i was requiring kind of like to pay
attention on the python um you know
classes because there is really a
one-to-one mapping between those those
python classes and the configuration
that is available for you to actually um
you know modify so whenever you use the
uh ml server uh hugging phase runtime
you know there's sort of run times like
you know like gbm or socket learn or xg
boost cetera but specifically the
hogging phase one exposes these
parameters right
first of all you have the ability to
specify which task you want to
leverage that's the pipeline itself in
this case you saw we were using text
generation but we're going to also show
how you can do question answering or you
can do sentiment analysis as well as the
many many other tasks that you have at
hand
you can then specify the pre-trained
model this is the repo location of the
hugging face hub where you're going to
be fetching it on and then you have the
ability to actually toggle whether you
want to use the optimized models or not
right so it very much is like you know
your model as code
sort of configuration based so that it's
reproducible whenever you want to like
rerun it of course this has a caveat
that is something that we normally
emphasize and maybe this is diverging a
bit but that requires uh to a certain
extent uh item potency on the buckets
right on your hocking face hub right by
name so this means that if you want to
like rerun this thing and it pulls the
artifact you're not just com like
overwriting it uh without without
versioning it in in the artifact itself
uh because otherwise you don't have the
item potency on on the definition by by
the configuration itself uh the second
step is to actually just run it right
after you create that config file the
only thing that you need to do is run ml
server start that actually uh runs uh
with fast api underneath um you know it
actually has like some architecture
where the fast api is the service
orchestrator and then you can have like
multi-processing of your models within
the python itself and that means that
you can actually consume um that
component um
right the model that we deployed so you
can send an input of selden is very and
then the prediction is the generated
text selden is very curious about the
matter blah blah blah right so so pretty
cool uh initial uh overview so let's
have a look at uh an initial overview of
the um demo itself so um you know we
actually have a repo uh this was from
the uh kubecon
showcase
you can actually open it directly with
uh the code spaces so this is actually
something that i had not known about but
it's pretty cool gives you like a fully
fledged
environment
here you can see uh that we've already
defined that config file uh it is the
text generation um you know
configuration uh using the uh distilled
gpt2 this is the actual smaller slightly
smaller model uh because otherwise you
know we would be waiting here uh for it
to download uh the multiple gigabytes uh
then we actually run the ml server start
what ml server does it actually runs
that hogging face
step it pulls the model uh so it you
know downloads the whole internet those
two gigabytes uh and you can open the um
yeah
open api documentation where you can
actually consume it interactively this
is again important right because you
want to make sure that it you know you
test it in the case of the hugging phase
models maybe there's a little bit more
uh of a simpler deterministic behavior
but when you have like a custom python
artifact that you're you know releasing
and deploying there may be some some
challenges so here you can see that you
know there has been uh an automatically
generated one that says you know i love
artificial intelligence and it generated
if you're an ai you would love to know
something something um right so um yeah
so you see that it's it's it's quite
simple you can now
you know modify uh the the task itself
in this case the text classification is
a sentiment analysis you see that you
know we remove the pre-trained model
that means that it just downloads the
the default one which is a bert model
you can see that it actually downloaded
the uh distilbert which is the smaller
one and now if you actually send the
request in there which is also the i
love artificial intelligence then you
can see that yeah there is a uh response
of a sentiment an isos positive with 90
something percent probability right so
that's basically uh it is it's very sort
of like simple uh and that should show
you kind of like the uh steps that you
can carry out and if you go into the
documentation you know you'll have like
all of the tasks that he can basically
run through
for sentiment analysis etc so now we're
going to actually start diving in some
of the more interesting parts which is
you know of course the the deployment
one but how we can leverage some
optimization steps so that we can
showcase how
with gpu we can run uh you know
parallelization of multiple inputs with
things like uh micro batching uh or well
adaptive batching or micro batching and
we're going to talk a bit more about
what that is so yeah so now that we see
that it runs locally we can move to the
next step and just productionize our
model right put it into our scalable
infrastructure that is going to have
that specialized hardware and it's going
to perform the the the you know right
and relevant scheduling across the
different areas so for that we're going
to be using seldom core
so this is basically the kubernetes
based uh
deployment framework um so um you know
not to bore you uh to death may think
main thing that i want to emphasize is
that those parameters that we had within
ml server have a one-to-one mapping with
what you would define
in the custom resource definition so uh
you know at the
infrastructure level you know you would
still be able to have that item potency
with all of the models that you have
deployed
based on the configuration
specifications of that uh so yes this is
one to one align with with those and
again you know the way that you would
deploy it it's very similar but instead
of running an ml server you would
actually run that against the cluster it
would you know pull the artifact it
would run that uh rest jrpc and kafka
interface and then you can actually
consume that model through um the the
same method right the same api
and the only other thing to emphasize is
um you know when it comes to to the way
in which we actually serve the models um
the protocol that we use is a protocol
that we've worked uh cross-functionally
across multiple different players in the
industry with the triton team the
k-serve team uh now the mlflow
and torch torch serve teams they now all
have standardized to this protocol which
is great right it's looking towards
making sure that we know all have like
different schemas different payloads
across different areas and we want to
continue uh driving forward kind of this
adoption uh for this for this protocol
and similarly you know right now we're
using the hugging face framework but you
can run triton underneath and deploy
those models but yeah that's kind of a
bit of a
divergence so now the final step is is
how do you make sure
as us as practitioners as data science
practitioners that you don't have to
deal with these final steps of actually
deploying into kubernetes this is you
know quite important to make sure that
there is some programmatic automations
so that data data scientists can focus
on doing data science and whenever
models are ready and tested you know
locally they are actually you know
productionized in a way that it's
seamless for them to not have to become
experts in kubernetes or even
knowledgeable
to to an unreasonable extent into
kubernetes to be able to see whether
their actual models are being consumed
some of the best practices that we're
going to be covering is things like
githubs so this is basically being able
to deploy into the production
environments not by just modifying the
environments but instead by actually
having a config ass
deployment right so you put your
configuration and that syncs
consistently into your production
environment that means that whatever you
have in your in this case version
control system github repo is exactly
what you have in your production
environment and that's that's good for
many reasons not just you know for the
for the sake that you can have
reproducibility right the fact that you
can actually go to the model that was
deployed last year but also um if you
know there are some disaster disaster
recovery mechanisms if your cluster goes
down or needs to be migrated you can
actually do so by you know just copying
kind of like the state into a new a new
environment so we're going to be
actually doing that again as we
mentioned the data scientists should
only focus or not should only focus but
their main sort of focus is on the data
science side and potentially some of the
machine learning engineering but um to
create kind of like this this models uh
to to to build uh what is artifacts at
the end that can be productionized
then the machine learning engineer
itself would be able to create those
programmatic pipelines that map into the
specific use cases introducing things
that you know are well beyond the scope
but covering things like validation
integration tests unit tests and also
making sure that you can uh you know
create all of those
you know service level indicators
service level objectives that you're
expecting to
meet in production right and this could
be things basic like accuracy precision
recall uh with the operational uh
processes that involve uh the assessment
of those steps but more importantly uh
making sure that it is specific to the
use case right so the machine learning
engineer would be able to create those
those pipelines and then you would have
that programmatic flow that whenever a
model is ready it can be productionized
or it can be marked as ready so that
they can be assigned enough to be to be
deployed uh the way that we're gonna be
showing this is actually uh integrated
into azure using this github tool called
flux
flux basically just maps into a kit repo
and it just syncs that git repo into a
kubernetes environment
so let's actually dive into the final
demo so here you can actually see that
we have
a configuration of um you know our
kubernetes cluster uh this kubernetes
cluster itself is going to have uh you
know some gpu nodes uh because we're
going to be running some benchmarks to
show how you know this optimization
benefits on different areas and we're
going to be actually you know showing
how we've configured already this
github's integration so we have this git
repo containing the deployment
specifications this is what is going to
be synced every time that we modify this
uh you know specific
you know deployment manifests that is
what is going to be synced in the
cluster this actually has a cpu and a
gpu
deployment uh using that hogging phase
server and those parameters that we
talked about so that has the text
generation model using the distilled
gpt2 the only difference is that you can
see the device itself uh you know we
have a device that is device zero or uh
device one that is whether it's the gpu
or not as well as to make sure that it's
running in the gpu nodes themselves
right so that's that's the key thing
that we need to just uh you know see
once we actually uh you know configure
uh this integration that means that
we're going to see the models being
deployed
and once the models are deployed then we
can actually start consuming them so
here we can actually see that the
synchronization started
the models are now running in the
kubernetes cluster and similar to what
we did in the past now we can actually
just consume them by sending requests
right so we now have like a cpu uh model
that is deployed and a gpu model both of
them are our gpt-2 uh inference servers
themselves so we can actually reach
through them uh via the endpoints
themselves and those are kind of like
the the parameters that we've covered so
now the way that we're going to be
running uh some of these
tests is using um this tool called k6 so
this is a very cool uh benchmarking tool
which will allow us to actually just run
a benchmarking job uh to test what is
the request per second uh and
capabilities for the gpu versus the cpu
one uh here you can see that uh you know
the gpu heavily you know outperforms uh
the cpu model itself and this is you
know of course in a way uh you know
expected primarily uh when it comes to
uh the way that we're testing it it's
actually by sending uh batched uh uh you
know micro batched inputs right um and
just kind of like to emphasize on that
point this micro batch inputs is what
the the the model itself needs to
perform faster than the cpu one
otherwise it would perform about the
same speed right if they are processing
it one by one is going to be almost the
same in this case it actually like
performs it in a single
gpu clock speed right so you can have
like a hundred or or or or you know 300
at once and you can see like you know
10x 100x uh improvements uh between
between those so that's that's that's
the that's the uh first um uh you know
uh iteration uh of the of the showcase
uh now what we're going to be doing is
showing uh another sort of technique
that we can introduce for optimization
this is not micro batching this is
adaptive batching so whilst micro
batching we're actually performing uh
the batching itself in the clients right
we're actually like packaging 100
requests sending 100 requests and
receiving 100 responses what we're going
to be doing is we're going to be doing
adaptive batching which means that we're
going to be sending one request at a
time and then in the server itself we're
going to say for you know a window of
time of either 2 seconds or 100 requests
we are going to actually um you know
batch them into one and we're going to
like run them in inference at the same
time right so that that's what we're
going to be able to see and that will
also show us how we perform and maximize
the utilization of our gpu
and and also our cpu in in in this
context right because this is something
that we were discussing is something
that you want to make sure that you're
using if you're spending a lot of money
in specialized hardware you want to make
sure that you're actually utilizing it
at its maximum right so that's that's
one of the key things that that you want
to make sure uh that you do when
performing those those things so let's
actually like dive into some of those
parameters so here you can actually see
uh in the in the parameters that the
only thing that we have to specify and
you can also test it locally is the
maximum batch size so that's basically
how large the batch uh is expected as
well as then the maximum batch time
that you want to run it against right so
it's it's either or it either reaches in
this case 128 uh requests and then like
you know passes them to the gpu and then
like sends sends them back to all of the
relevant open connections or if like
three seconds pass then it actually like
takes whatever it has and then runs that
uh against um the um inference itself so
and the interesting thing about this is
that it is important for you to actually
run the relevant benchmarks to tweak
what is the best uh optimization for
both your model and the hardware itself
right so here you can see that you know
we're running another um
you know benchmark uh a test we're gonna
be seeing a an even better uh
improvement and you can see here that
actually the requests are being batched
uh in terms of the inference itself
right so every couple of requests it
actually performs inference once whereas
here it actually would perform inference
every single time as the requests go
through so that's basically uh the
overview of some of the optimizations
that you can do once you actually deploy
your model and one of the things that
you know we skim through but you know if
you're interested uh some of the
resources here um
delve into the monitoring considerations
right all of the principles
best practices around machine learning
monitoring
not just for operational monitoring
which is basically request per second
latency but also for advanced machine
learning monitoring which goes back into
the data centric machine learning
because it includes drift detectors
outlier detectors
adversarial detectors and those
themselves are models which also require
specialized hardware which also at risk
so you know you you do open into
considerations even when you introduce
things that in theory reduce the risk
now within your your machine learning
stack um so yeah so so that was kind of
like the initial overview what we
actually were able to see uh you know
was very very broad we were able to see
how uh you know uh individuals are able
to convert in this case data into
machine learning artifacts whether
you know through a jupiter notebook
manually or using some etl work uh
workflow based uh uh system uh then
being able to deploy these artifacts
either manually or through some
programmatic
ci cd methodology as well as you know
through githubs itself and then the
ability to productionize
those artifacts
once they have been tested and validated
locally uh the one there's some things
that we didn't discuss was the
advanced monitoring techniques which you
can delve into but we'll still uh you
know reflect into some of the
optimization you know considerations
that we discussed you may also want to
introduce optimizations to your drift
detectors or at light detectors etc etc
and then you know of course the loopback
of the inference data that goes through
you know to make sure that you can take
advantage of that in your training data
as i emphasized uh all of the resources
you know you can find them in this link
so
you know we have tons of other talks
actually several that were the pi data
in the last couple of years one that
dives into ci cd for production machine
learning on production machine learning
monitoring with
drift detectors i like detectors
explainers uh you know this one on
accelerating ml inference at scale and
then a more recent one which
is now actually a very important topic
of machine learning security and um the
concept of best practices actually we
talk about it as bad practices through
flood machine learning uh so first
identifying what's what we shouldn't do
and then and then defining what we
should
so so yeah so so
you know just to summarize today we were
able to actually delve into some of the
motivations uh of uh machine learning
acceleration we talked about uh our
recent collaboration uh with microsoft
and uh you know hogging face to bring
this uh integration with the hugging
face hub as well as this optimizations
that can be done at the artifact and
also at the inference layer and then
some best practices that can be
introduced
to minimize the interaction with mlaps
where possible so with that
thank you very much and i'm more than
happy to answer any questions so thank
you
lovely thank you alejandro questions
alejandro
follow the back there we go
thanks for the talk really interesting
um wanted to ask how does seldom compare
to sagemaker inference or even
a hygiene phase inference api
yeah you know that's a great question so
so how you face uh you know recently
they have the integration with uh azir
so they allow you to deploy endpoints so
that basically is in a way a managed
service that you know allows you to just
just integrate with that sagemaker does
also provide a serving of their
containers again
very well integrated with the sagemaker
ecosystem
seldom core itself is more like a set of
uh
i guess emelop's lego blocks that allow
you to bring it into your own
infrastructure so this is uh kubernetes
uh cloud native uh and uh the way that
we built it so that it integrates with
all of the broad set of heterogeneous
model training systems ml flow also
sagemaker vertex ai uh azure ml
et cetera et cetera so it really is more
for
use cases where you're building your own
internal um envelopes uh uh a platform
uh so i think i think that that's the
the primary use case that we see however
having said that uh you can see that
there's a lot of intersection and
collaboration uh with some of those uh
other uh platforms uh primarily because
there's also relevant use cases for
those which are which are potentially
more more vertical selling tends to be
seen more as kind of like that central
serving platform like the devops
environment
where all all the sort of models kind of
like get orchestrated into uh but yeah
probably uh more resources in the
documentation so i definitely point you
to that for you to check kind of like
the full list of features
love yourselves any more questions for
alejandro
thanks thanks for the talk
um
it seems that the the kind of
framework that you presented is in a
sort of sweet spot between data science
and devops
so like in more traditional teams they
have like data scientists and have
devops so who is actually responsible
for building and maintaining that
um
sort of like how do you reduce the
tension between data scientists and
devops
that's a great question yeah yeah so so
that is a really good question so so the
way that that we see it and this is of
course still kind of like an incomplete
work in progress picture as we are all
figuring it out
the way that we have seen it is that
there is
starting to become kind of a
standardized organizational structure
where you would have data scientists
machine learning engineers and devops
engineers
each of them
with kind of like a smaller ratio right
like you would have perhaps one devops
engineer to multiple machine learning
engineers who are maintaining multiple
use cases which are kind of like being
continuously uh provisioned by multiple
data scientists right so so what we see
specifically on who builds the
infrastructure uh we see it as multiple
different levels um we actually agree
that i totally agree with your point
that this does seem to be quite an
interesting sweet spot
because um this has this machine
learning engineering has been the
intersection where we have been able to
see uh where we can kind of like touch
uh some of the use cases and use surveys
of hugging face which is primarily more
kind of like the data science and
machine learning engineer seldom core is
more on the devops and machine learning
engineers so
we tend to see that machine learning
engineering function itself is the one
responsible for building what you know i
refer to as use case pipelines right so
these reproducible uh programmatic
integrations with etl or ci type
pipelines that allow for that continuous
delivery of a particular machine
learning model type use case so so i
would say that role is the one that
tends to kind of like help reduce some
of the friction having said that there
is still some ambiguity where you find a
lot of data scientists
you know leaking working into the
machine learning engineering roles uh
building their own sort of like
fast api or flask
wrappers and then you know deploying
them and then realizing oh no now i am
actually having to like uh be careful
with the uptime and be responsible of
the uptime of my service and they're
like okay devops person your problem um
so i would say yeah the machine learning
engineering function is kind of like uh
the one responsible building kind of
like those integrations but not the
infrastructure that would still be kind
of like devops
yeah so hopefully that gave a little bit
yeah more picture
love yourself such a cool time now
alejandra will be around afterwards to
answer questions if you have them for
him and haven't been asked at the moment
but before that another round of
applause for our speaker
you